we're going to keep delving into the
anti-trans Panic as a result of the
shooting in Nashville Tennessee but one
of the things that is front of mind for
me and there's a very good Vice news
article about this is that the trans
identity of the Nashville Tennessee
shooter despite the fact that what
three or four out of the last 5 000 Mass
Shooters have been not even necessarily
trans either non-binary or trans like
four out of five thousand okay despite
that all of a sudden
the right Wingers are seeing the trans
identity of the Nashville shooter as the
opening to declare full-scale war
against the trans Community I'm
extraordinarily concerned about our
trans friends and allies because I do
believe that they are at serious risk
like it's not an exaggeration I think
that there this is this is an over
threat we are now seeing uh for for
several years now to be perfectly honest
I have pointed out to you that at events
like CPAC and others the biggest
Applause lines even at Trump rallies the
biggest Applause lines come during the
anti-trans moments of speeches when Ted
Cruz says my pronouns are kiss my ass
and everybody stands in cheers and Trump
says we must not allow teachers to teach
transgender without parental consult I
mean consent
and the crowd cheers and they go crazy
um this has been building for a while
and it's now open season Vice news
writing the right is using the Nashville
shooting to declare war on trans people
it has been an online barrage towards
basically any visible trans person
online Tucker Carlson did a segment in
which he claims that the trans Community
is actually targeting Christians we're
going to talk about that separately I
don't even want to delve into that now
because it really deserves its own
segment but as the article says as soon
as details started to emerge about the
shooter in Nashville pundits and
politicians on the Right started
exploiting the tragedy to spread
anti-trans hate you know almost every
Mass shooter is a young white male not
all of them but most of them you look at
the last 5 000 mass shootings like I
said it's overwhelmingly young white men
and so when that is the case
all of a sudden many of these right-wing
networks and people have nothing to say
they have nothing to say now to a
certain extent when their Kyle kolinsky
said this yesterday in a great video
which I'll talk about later that he did
about my controversy related to the
shooting he said you know these
shootings are so common that like when
three people are killed in a shooting
we all say do we talk about is this a
story because there's like three of
these A Day in the United States is this
a story and for many of these right
Wingers when it is the what we call it
imagine we have like our traditional
mass shooting in the U.S young white
male
gets an AR-15 maybe also a handgun and
goes crazy and starts shooting people
either because of we've seen every we've
seen everything disgruntled employment
employment stuff targeting a particular
race we've seen all of it we've seen all
of it is it even a story and it isn't
always a story and a lot of the right
Wingers don't even comment
all of a sudden
the trans identity of this individual is
exposed and reported on and every right
winger wants to talk about it this is
the important mass shooting to talk
about never mind that there have been I
mean if we want to be precise what is
the uh let's see how many mass shootings
have there already been since this one
um oh I don't have an updated list okay
oh wait last 72 hours
uh so let's see one two there's been a
bunch of mass shootings since this one
but they want to talk about the one with
the Trans shooter and the most important
takeaways of course are that these are
people who don't actually want to do
anything about guns their priority if
they do talk about a shooting or if they
don't talk about a shooting it's to
serve their primary purpose which is
don't deal with guns don't look at
implementing any of the 10 ideas that I
presented to you yesterday one trans
person
versus how how many non-trans mass
Shooters so transgenderism must be the
problem drag shows which don't have
anything to do with it must be the
problem all of them have guns but the
guns aren't the problem
oh but mental illness is the problem but
we don't want to commit any money to
treating Mental Illness but now that the
the shooter is trans then we must spread
transphobia we must spread anti-lgbt
sentiment in general and it's disturbing
and it's depressing Marjorie Taylor
green particularly disgusting she is
calling for Trans Vengeance she has been
suspended from Twitter and we will talk
about that separately again because I
believe it's its own form of evil which
we will discuss and of course then we
always go back to
when people like me say hey
I've had a proposal with 10 different
Provisions to deal with some of the gun
aspects of this I've had the proposal
for for years David it's too soon to
politicize the tragedy we must not make
it political
really when we actually want to look at
solutions to the problem it's too soon
but it is never too soon to spread hate
and to say well drag time story hour is
what caused this what and I don't even
want to go into this yet because there's
a lot of allegations flying around but
what really may be at issue here what
really may be at issue here is the
treatment of the individual
and who ultimately did this
at that school and we're still learning
more about that and and hopefully at
some point we will know the full story
but it is open season on the trans
Community we all need to be extremely
concerned about this and we're going to
continue talking about it more make sure
you're subscribed to the YouTube channel
youtube.com the davidpackman show so
much coming up on the program today